good morning believe nation today's
message is go for what you want to get
over to you Bethenny Frankel awake
compare mood in espresso TV go I like
the idea of this a place of yes tell us
a little bit about what that phrase
means you know it's not it's not about
always being in a good mood because we
could all tell by tonight's show that
I'm not always that um it's about the
fact that you go for what you want to
get and and there's no such thing as
know and you get derailed and sometimes
you don't know you know where you are
you can't see the forest for the trees
I've had tons of jobs and tons of
failures buddy always been on the road
I've always been moving forward and I've
always known I'm gonna get it i'm gonna
be something i'm going to help people i
have something and you know everyone's
told me know along the way and you have
to go in your own go for your own good
and grab your balls and go for it so
what do you think um I don't know I
don't remember the last time I go for it
but everything I want I always get it I
don't wait you just go for it I just go
for it yeah i'm the same way I'm not
somebody who has all these lists of
things that I want to do at some point
as soon as I get it into my head that I
want to do something just start doing
this trip really lasts me like I don't
want to be here nears I don't want to be
in front of the ears back away when I
set a goal that I want to hit a million
subscribers that's what I'm working all
in towards it's not like hey in three
years or my five year goal door one day
I'm going to do that so if you have a
goal just go do it stop saying someday
someday is not a day too weak just do it
right now do it take action every single
day 30 to 60 minutes at least every
single day make sure that you see it in
your head as crystal clear as you can it
just start taking actual probably won't
happen realize it good well thank you
guys so much for watching the question
of the day today is what was the last
thing that you want to get leave your
comments below will join the discussion
thank you guys so much again for
watching having a
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shut up and press 0 hi guys hi
okay this recipe me go